let's go first to
uh josh from mexico city
josh i would love to hear what's going
on there
hi david can you hear me i i can i i
can't help but
ask where you are exactly because it's
such a compelling background noise
uh the park you're at the park all right
park in mexico city i've got a picture
in my head what's going on there yeah
so i had a question for you it seems
like the the biden administration
one of their big things was was racial
justice
and um and since the united nations
uh committee on uh i believe it's
unrecognized
or uh decolonization has specifically
called up the us
in terms of its relationship with with
the territories and overseas possessions
um does it seem likely that and also
given that puerto rico
uh has more or less
[Music]
definitively voted on on statehood
if you call it that um does it seem
likely that
the biden administration will make a
an attempt to uh sort of normalize the
status of the
of the territories especially american
samoa where they're not
where they don't even have the right to
birthright citizenship you know
it doesn't strike me that this is going
to be
at the top of the list of priorities for
democrats
and for joe biden's administration in
these first two years to me
and this is not my opinion of what
should happen i think it should be a
priority
it seems to me that it's more likely to
be a sort of 2022 to 2024
priority and then of course you need to
wait and see if democrats will even have
the house
and or senate that's my sense right now
i'm not seeing like a big political
appetite for it and particularly when
you know stimulus was going to be done
right away it took months i i i'm not
super optimistic it gets done in these
first two years sure
sure but thanks thanks david what are
you doing in mexico city
do you live there yes i i'm half chicano
okay so i uh i was here working on my
phd before
before lockdown and uh so now i live
here
how are things from the standpoint of
the virus
it's complicated yeah um the the the
government
has started to roll out
the the russian vaccine yep um but of
course you have
this this is of course a country where
that's that's complicated
you know you could say it's only been a
democracy for the past 20 years
and uh you know you have people you have
you have
the the informal and formal economy
right people who work in the formal
economy are
are are doing okay it's the people who
work in the informal economy that have
received no no protection are there ways
if you are an elite so to speak to get
the pfizer or modern vaccines there
uh what i've what i've what i've heard
from some friends
um is that people are going to their uh
summer houses in in florida to get it
right or things of that nature that that
seems to be the best way
yep to do it i've read that about
argentina as well people people who were
going to miami
yeah yeah yeah it's that's pretty much
that's pretty much
what's what's happening and what's
what's what's also interesting is that
when they did the
initial contact tracing they traced the
first case of
actually the first cluster of cases in
mexico city to
uh a group of uh elites who
who went to aspen oh really the
quarantine yes
so not shocking not shocking all right
josh thank you appreciate the call
yeah thank you david all right there's a
josh
from mexico city let's go next to sarah
from washington d.c
sarah you're on the air hey hi how are
you
i'm good how are you doing well i've
actually never talked
to you before um i watch everything you
do
um yeah um
i'm just honestly here to listen and
like learn
from oh you didn't want to ask a
question i mean
you know i'm just listening and here i
like what you do so i'm just here to
listen and take in what i can
i didn't really have a specific question
all right well thank you i appreciate it
of course all right there we go sarah
from washington dc
today's episode is sponsored by bluechu
a unique
online service delivering the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost and they're giving my audience an
entire month's
supply for free take a short quiz on the
bluechew website
a licensed doctor approves your
prescription and the medication goes
right to your home in a discreet package
no driving to the doctor's office having
a possibly awkward conversation waiting
in line at the pharmacy
bluechu replaces the entire process with
a few
clicks and way less expensive and all of
blue chews tablets are made
in the united states so if you think you
could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
go to bluechew.com the link is under
this video and they'll give you an
entire month's supply for
free when you use promo code pacman just
pay five dollars for shipping